Olá queridos seguidores Dr aland Dutra
aqui acetina é o flavonoide mais
amplamente distribuído e extensivamente
estudado muitos estudos têm destacado as
suas atividades anticancerígenas
antiinflamatórias antialérgicas e
antivirais quando acetina se une a
outras substâncias como a bromelaína ou
zinco os seus benefícios se expandem
ainda mais ela é na verdade um doss
antioxidantes mais consumidos na nossa
dieta e tem uma missão incrível mente
valiosa combater os danos causados pelos
radicais livres os efeitos do
envelhecimento e a inflamação embora uma
dieta saudável e equilibrada seja uma
excelente maneira de obter essa
substância maravilhosa algumas pessoas
optam por tomá-la como suplemento
buscando o impacto ainda mais potente
por isso pessoal não é exagero quando
dig que recomendo manter acetina próxima
de você Especialmente nos momentos em
que sentir que algo não vai bem como os
primeiros sinais de um resfriado ou
gripe Quais são os benefícios reais da
quece Sina pra sua saúde pra minha saúde
o primeiro benefício que eu tenho o
prazer de compartilhar com vocês é algo
que em nossa vida moderna muitos de nós
enfrentamos mesmo que não saibamos que é
a inflamação crônica como parte da
família dos flavonoides acetina Age
combatendo o desgaste natural do nosso
corpo causado pela oxidação e aqui Vai
um alerta a inflamação é um dos
principais gatilhos de inúmeras doenças
desde problemas cardíacos até declínio
cognitivo quem aqui já teve que lidar
com aqueles sintomas desagradáveis de
alergias sazonais ou até mesmo alergias
alimentares bem você pode surpreender ao
saber que a quetin tem sido considerada
por muitos como antihistamínico natural
agora para aqueles que não estão
familiarizados as estaminas são
substâncias químicas liberadas pelo
nosso sistema
imunológico sempre que detecta uma
alergia são elas as culpadas por
sintomas como tosse espirro olho
lacrimejante coriza até ticara o poder
da quetin está em sua capacidade ajudar
a estabilizar a membrana dos mastócitos
para que ele não libere a estamina
diminuindo assim o sintomas indesejados
e um pequeno bônus para os que buscam
alívio de alergia combinar a ctina com
outros suplementos como o caso de Urtiga
de oica gengibre vitamina C e vitamina D
pode potencializar os seus efeitos
benéficos prosseguindo com a nossa lista
de benefícios o terceiro é o efeito
antiviral da quetin pessoal ela tem um
papel crucial como ionóforo de zinco mas
o que que isso significa basicamente ela
ajuda a transportar o zinco diretamente
para dentro de nossas células isso é
fundamental para impedir a replicação de
vírus e assim fortalecer a nossa defesa
contra gripes e resfriados outro fato
interessante é que acetina e vitamina C
são uma ótima dupla dinâmica quando
usadas juntas elas trabalham de forma
unificada sinérgica a vitamina C
potencializa os níveis plasmáticos de
que cetina tornando ainda mais eficaz em
seus efeitos de combater diversos vírus
nosso quarto benefício destacados é a
proteção ao fígado em pesquisas
realizadas com ratos que tiveram lesão é
pática induzida pelo álcool a
administração de quercetina mostrou
efeitos protetores significativos esse
antioxidante poderoso auxilia na
melhoria das atividades das enzimas que
metabolizam o álcool reforça o sistema
antioxidante contra o estresse oxidativo
e ainda reduz as expressões citocinas
pró-inflamatórias proporcionando alívio
ao fígado um ponto notável que um estudo
de 2017 identificou acetina como um
potencial tratamento para doenças
hepáticas fibróticas uma condição que
surge devido a lesões e inflamações no
fígado agora que já entendemos Os
Incríveis benefícios da quercetina é
essencial saber onde encontrá-la não é
mesmo começando pelas frutas temos as
cítricas maçãs com destaque pras cascas
que são especialmente ricas em quetin
uvas vermelhas cerejas ameixas e frutas
vermelhas como mirtilo Amora e Cranberry
acetina está presente em de tomates
vegetais de folha verde brócolis
especialmente nas cebolas roxas e não
podemos esquecer das pimentas e do chá
verde e falando em cebolas roxas um fato
interessante suas cascas podem conter
até 77 vezes mais quercetina do que a
polpa embora comer casca de cebola não
seja exatamente apetitoso você pode
considerar preparar um caldo com elas ou
mesmo fazer uma farinha das cascas de
cebola para os seus benefícios
potencializados para quem considera
suplementar geralmente é seguro consumir
até 500 mg duas vezes ao dia por até 12
semanas contudo antes de prolongar a
suplementação é recomendado consultar um
profissional de saúde muitos suplementos
de quetin são oferecidos em comprimidos
ou cápsulas e frequentemente combinados
com outros ingredientes que amplificam
os seus efeitos antiinflamatórios um
exemplo notável é a combinação de quetin
com bromelaína ou brumel uma enzima
encontrada no abacaxxi que pode
potencializar o controle de alergias e
aqui vai uma dica preciosa para otimizar
os benefícios da quetin considere
consumi-la à noite idealmente combinada
com zinco e após um período de jejum de
TR a 4 horas durante o sono em condições
metabólicas ideais acetina exerce aação
cultic que é para eliminar as células
velh células zumbis essas células
pararam de se dividir perderam a
funcionalidade e estão relacionadas ao
envelhecimento elas podem acelerar o
envelhecimento e causar várias doenças
ao utilizar agentes senoliticos que
matam células zumbis como acetina
realizamos uma desintoxicação celular
promovendo uma saúde otimizada e
envelhecimento mais saudável mas mesmo
sendo benéfica como tudo o consumo
excessivo pode ter contraindicações em
doses elevadas pode causar dor de cabeça
e formigamento em braços e pernas assim
use com moderação muito Obrigado pela
sua atenção pelo seu carinho Um grande
abraço um beijo no seu coração você é
feira